Hmm.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Fabulous.
Big,
big,
big money,
right?
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
I love that song.
And you're right.
We need to play that more.
Yeah.
That's a,
I believe that was maximum and that did that
amazing work on the show.
Um,
so thanks as always to all the various
good
musicians that submit songs and instrumentals.
This is a
sounds made the beat.
That's what made that,
this song has this instrumental is called Bangor's.
Bang a man.
You are naturally,
you are the president
of southern California chapter
this weekend.
I'm in smear my juice New York,
um,
otherwise known as Syracuse for show is just Friday,
Saturday.
That's the way it works,
man.
Very excited about it now.
And it might even turn your,
your thing thinking.
Yeah man.
Um,
and then
couple weeks later he comes,
see the God in Your Ein California at the Improv,
also known as Irvine Sperm Sperm Bine Zany Comedy Club in Gasfield,
Tennessee in June
11.
Comedy Club,
West nut sack New York.
That's a June 23rd through 25th.
I like nuts sack.
That's good.
Really good,
uh,
shits in natty.
Yes.
The,
I'm doing the new funny bone in liberty township.
All my sense people,
man.
Diego,
Mandy,
Lego's,
uh,
during the American comedy company,
July 14,
15 and 16,
um,
Saint Jude,
Ted's Missoura,
helium,
July 21st to 23rd
now two pork titties.
You dork titties.
I thought dude,
Org titties.
Caroline's September eight,
nine,
10.
Hey Philly,
fill her up.
Delphia uh,
we sold out,
I might show in November 19th at the truck at Arrow.
So we added one,
uh,
November 18th,
the truck in Philly tickets are on sale.
Everything I listed is that Tom,
cigarette.com/shows a bunch of cities will be added.
I have them book,
they're just not on sale yet,
so look forward to it.
Genes.
What do you got?
Uh,
May 27th and 28 I'm at the La Jolla comedy star,
La Jolla,
California.
Come see me and I'm working on a bunch of one nighters and around the country.
So look out for me probably in the fall.
And then every Saturday,
usually I'm at the comedy store and the original room at the seven 30 show,
unless I'm in La Jolla,
but I'm,
I'm there usually every time they come see me.
Great.
Oh,
is next week.
But then after that I met the store in Hollywood most Saturdays at the seven 30
show in 70.
Mommy's had come out three or four shows.
What are you doing it?
I'm doing four shows Friday and Saturday the 27th and 28th in Lajolla good.
Yeah,
it's like seven 30 and nine 30 to shows were just perfect.
It's your first flag for show weekend in awhile.
Yeah.
And I know and the full charge will be there as well.
He's opening for me and it should be really fun.
I can't wait.
I hear it's a great club here.
It's one of the best I've ever been.
I've never done lawyer ever.
I was surprised.
I know,
I know.
There were good,
I heard great things.
Professional Acne.
Um,
well,
all right.
Go to a thousand ranch.com that's right.
For a link to the signature.
That's right.
Yeah.
All right.
Jeans.
Let's start the show,
man.
Hold on.
Use our Amazon banner.
Or please,
please,
please.
When you do your shopping,
go to your mom's house,
podcast dot cop car
Gaza.
Try to give us roadblocks,
rigid,
amazing.
Um,
for fuckboys.
And what makes somebody a fuckboy?
I mean,
this is a better word for hate.
Her Mad people,
bumps,
losers,
garbage piece of shit.
She kind of,
how you do that?
Don't bring in one loving to them.
Well,
well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Um,
I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to cut off.
I didn't mean to you though.
That was
so rude.
Why?
I,
I'm,
I'm confused.
I'm like,
Dad,
this fucking thing,
man.
You know,
I want to just pull it up and,
and have it placed right.
Starts playing.
I am just,
you know,
you're not very bright.
All right.
Anyways,
uh,
use our Amazon banner.
Go to your mom's house podcast.
Satcom kicked,
cleared on the banner at the homepage and do your shopping as you normally
would.
There you go.
And help us.
That's how it helps our show.
It's like the best way to support your mom's house.
And it's,
it's what you were going to buy anyways.
That's the truth of it.
I know.
It's fantastic.
I masturbated.
Yeah.
I didn't even know you were in the room.
That's I know how weird and apropos of the show.
Yeah.
Well cause we were took a shower together and I was Todd's in your kibbles and
bits and I,
and I was like,
I don't know if we have time to really get one in or whatnot even suggest that.
But I was thinking it in my head.
I go,
I,
I don't know if you have touch right again,
you did participate in the shower and you're like,
I gotta go in the shower.
Ooh,
really fucks in the shower.
I mean now I can't,
I'm on,
my bones are all out of whack now.
Okay.
Anyways,
I wasn't sure what the little bass,
hello.
And now I'm talking again,
but you see what I'm trying to do.
I'm just trying to set it up and it starts playing.
I'm just trying to like place it.
I wasn't sure my blue band would come over and I didn't know if we had time
there.
That's the story.
Then you got out of the shower and I saw you in the bed.
Well,
I saw you go into the closet and then I saw you come out and then I was like,
oh,
at first,
actually I didn't know if you were in the closet or not.
And then I was like,
oh,
she's not in there.
I didn't hear any noise.
So I was like,
oh,
there's no one in the room.
I'll crank one out.
Yeah.
And then I did and uh,
uh,
stuff happened and you know,
and then I was like,
no.
And I was like,
do you want to do it now?
Let's do it.
We got a few minutes.
Then what happened?
Then you go,
you can,
they blew my note and then I say it like that.
I already did it,
eh,
he got us Stip Dick Right after I tried to have marital Catholic love with you
and you spilled your seed carelessly in the shower.
Yup,
that's true.
You know what I was thinking to myself,
I was like,
dude,
he's taken a really long shower and it's not like you,
you usually,
first of all,
you don't really clean anything.
Like you got to blow your nose,
you shake around like a dog and then you get out.
I was just trying to make sure I was,
I was actually extra quiet.
I should have been more.
Oh my God,
I should have done that.
Oh Man.
But I was,
I was actually like,
oh what a show.
Cause I thought you might've been walking around.
Yeah.
And then that didn't deter you whatsoever.
Where I turned myself away from the,
it's a very,
it's not the ideal bathroom for masturbating.
No.
Pleasantly No.
Cause there's no door between the bedroom and the showers and especially once
Ellis starts walking.
I'm sure he's going to want to see you.
We've got time.
Okay.
You can walk it in on your dad cranky when it,
is there anything more scarring?
Your Dad wants to remain a master?
Nope.
What that might be.
The only thing I haven't seen.
Then your parents used to like not really be big on clothes though when you're
really young.
Yeah,
we'll we're European.
Yeah.
It was naked all the time.
Everybody was nude and no weird.
No.
I saw my mom naked all the time.
And Your Dad all the time?
My dad naked all the time.
I had a friend come over when I was like 11 and she was like,
your dad's naked.
And I'm like,
Oh yeah,
daddy could put on something.
There's a friend.
He's like,
oh,
okay.
Why?
No.
I think he first went,
why?
I'm like,
Where would he be naked and the backyard.
We lived in Canoga Park in the backyard and he liked to sunbathe nude.
That was what he was doing is just always naked in the back yard.
I should preface it by saying,
and whoever was over whatever girlfriend there naked in the backyard,
just sunbathing.
It was very natural.
And that doesn't strike you now as really bizarre though.
No.
Because?
Because when you grow up with naked parents,
no,
but now you have perspective.
So No.
If Ella saw me nude,
if I don't think I'd give a shit,
I still don't think so.
I don't care what it's not sexual.
There were European babe and your pants are just naked.
Only Americans are uptight about nudity.
No,
I can't.
If you're a European right in and let us know that it's normal,
that everybody's naked,
they're not going to tell you it's normal.
What about my dad drinking a 12 or every night?
I think it's normal for a man to be nude around 10 and 11 year olds and then,
and then you go put on some clothes and he was like,
why?
Right.
Well then that's the thing is that I had to tell my dad that that wasn't
appropriate.
And America,
that you can't just be naked.
Why it appropriate anywhere else though?
I don't think it is.
I don't think a Hungarian thing.
I don't know.
So,
but then he started putting on like [inaudible] people were over and then
eventually I became a teenager and then he covered up.
Yeah.
But when I became a teenager,
he stopped.
But you're 10 and 11 nude walking around the house nude.
Yeah,
yes.
Everybody in my family.
Yes.
My mother was naked all the time,
tops and bottoms,
tops and bottoms.
I'd see my mom been really close her vagina like a ton of times.
All the time.
Yeah.
It's just normal.
It was normal baby.
My mom had big soggy hangers.
Topless.
You said naked?
Yes.
She come out of the shower and she would be talking to me like we get ready for,
oh,
and then my mom would like run through the house and go to the kitchen naked to
grab something as she was coming out of the truck.
It wasn't like we were new this,
but if somebody took a shower and then like had to grab something,
another part of the house.
So just crawl,
you know,
walked around.
Well you never saw anybody charro top dog soon to masturbate.
Of course.
That's like a very common bonding thing for most for most fathers and sons.
America.
No,
I'm serious.
But you've seen your dad's nuts and and dick.
Yeah,
but not a lot.
And not on it,
like on accident,
like walking in and change everything out,
but not,
not with any regularity.
Oh yeah.
People just walk around.
It wasn't,
it wasn't like a lifestyle.
Actually have another person in the room did tie normal.
He crept normal.
Well,
yeah,
we're trying to do,
we're trying to establish what's normal.
Right?
American.
Both Israeli parents,
Shit.
Israelis are nudists aren't they?
Kind of,
nope.
So I'm learning that my childhood was way fucked up.
I didn't realize it.
I'm 40 years old.
What do you,
what's your vote?
I mean,
I've seen,
well,
I'm not watching on my dad.
How about the idea of nudity?
Just kind of being walking around.
That's weird.
Jews are funny.
Well,
I don't like if Ellis walks in on me changing,
what am I supposed to?
Oh no,
of course not.
No,
but that's different.
That's totally going to you.
The difference is walking in on you changing and you being like,
I'm just laying around with what dick out Saturday friend over here.
You're 10.
What's up?
Like you don't think that that's,
yeah,
that's true.
I never thought of it that way.
It was so normal.
Yeah.
It must've really been.
Normally you,
there wasn't like erotic.
It didn't feel sexy or anything.
I just,
I didn't think he thought it felt sexy.
It's my dad.
I like how you take it there.
Felt sexy.
That's wrong with you.
You're,
my dad also taught me to shoot guns in the backyard when I was nine.
That's a normal,
yes.
Okay.
Yes,
of course.
If you're supposed to just checking.
Yeah.
Were you allowed to drink beer as child?
MMM,
no,
I think but,
but probably way before certain super conservative families,
you know?
Yeah.
Like I had sips of stuff young.
MMM.
But I was allowed to drink,
have a drink in the house with dinner.
Uh,
probably by the time I was in high school.
Yeah.
I'll see.
That's good.
That's normal.
Yeah.
I think that's not,
not like I got like you're 11,
right?
Here's a glass of whiskey.
Although that's when I was 10 when I had my first sip of whiskey,
but it was a sip and I was like,
I think I'm gonna throw up.
Yeah.
I couldn't believe people liked it.
Okay.
All right.
So who is this guy?
Is that back home?
This is David Beckham.
And,
uh,
he's talking to the Dj Khaled about,
how long have your Dj friends?
I want his jewelry so badly.
You can,
you can get on camera.
This album an uppercut in a knockoff.
And I always wonder when you say these things core,
you fighting when you call this a victory.
Who did you defeat the fuck boys?
And that's what's he doing now?
You can answer the question.
You can eat the wing.
It's not the Olympics here.
Yeah.
But um,
yeah,
the fuck boys.
The guys that try to give us roadblocks,
those wings look good.
Yeah.
I want language.
I know me too.
For fuckboys.
And what makes somebody a fuck boy,
good question.
I mean,
this is a better word for hater.
Mad people,
bumps losers,
garbage pizza.
Shit.
I like this guy going to hire you.
Do that.
I like that.
Can I tell you there's probably no worse premise for a talk show than eating as
you're talking.
That's also the hook of it.
Not yet.
And they eat increasingly hotter wings throughout.
Yeah.
It's just gross to watch him.
Yeah,
I know.
And the hearing that right?
Yeah.
It's like listening to be smalls rab.
He was always showing
no,
it's true.
He's always sounded like he was eating that.
That was just the fat of his mouth.
She'll fucking fat.
Yeah.
But anyway,
uh,
folklore,
I think that's a loose definition.
I still think it's in reference to homosexuals.
Well,
but it's actually encompassing.
I think it's fair to encompass everything.
Loser.
Just say it more.
Are you saying it more now?
Are you in cut like in your visiting your lexicon boy.
Oh,
well,
hopefully we can say more.
Know what?
I'm going to make a note of that.
Uh,
at the comedy store,
the Saturday,
I'm going to incorporate the word fuck a boy boy to be jet stroller.
Boy.
Yeah.
You don't want to cause a nonbinary fuckboy or is it binary?
That's another great point.
That's a maybe,
uh,
maybe,
maybe there's your bit right there.
Maybe that's the whole new bit.
What,
how should I be spelling?
Fuck boy.
Boy,
boy.
Boy is the way to go.
But wait a minute.
But boys are women that identify masculine.
That's the whole,
I would say f,
And if you cc that's what's up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well the fuck.
That's how you should say you're so handsome.
Thanks.
I do love you.
Some days.
Oh,
Wednesdays where she would have done it with paint today.
I know.
I wanted to,
I was,
I was busy by myself.
Do you make those noises?
Sometimes.
I was real quiet though.
Thinking about Rihanna and where you like stay up off my Instagram.
I was like thinking about sex with Rihanna loose.
Be Amazed.
You mean you don't masturbate to your wife?
What?
Yeah,
I was like my wife,
my wife
or women dumb enough.
Uh,
that they think that can I have a cup of diarrhea please?
People have been tweeting what's in the cup?
It looks like diarrhea.
Well,
it's dog diarrhea and it's excellent.
Liked it.
And it was because we microwave it,
we reheat it and then it explodes in the microwave.
That's it looks,
it looks like diarrhea.
It's not microwave.
Not this particular cup,
but mine often is and then it looks like it's splatter diarrhea.
Oh,
I got you.
I thought you meant the color complexion of it.
Oh,
you mean sometimes he's just splattered heat.
It too much you like.
That's a weird thing about you.
Weird thing about you.
You hate hot food.
Hate it,
and you'll microwave this shit at a coffee.
It'd be so hot.
Have you drink?
That's the only thing I like hot.
It's
so bizarre.
I mean,
you're always walking around with your tits out in front of our child.
He's going to see him.
Of course.
He'd be like,
mom,
you don't.
He's going to see dad's Dick.
Dad's Dick.
That's a great title for your next special.
Yup.
Did we have come up with a good one for you?
Dad's dicks.
No.
Remember I was right before you left the other day.
Something about my tits.
Yeah.
Slop or central or something.
Sloppers cow.
My tits are ruined.
Not ruined.
Anyways,
what else?
When we talk about the,
the Americans we got into that show,
Americans is great.
Oh,
wonderful.
It's not mark and the American Americans is real good.
Um,
it's really something to find a show you can buy into that's really well done.
Yeah.
I'm really into highly recommend.
Obviously a lot of people have watched it.
This is the new way I think of watching shows.
It's no longer about watching a show
as it airs all the time.
No,
I mean everyone's going to have the few,
they do that with.
It's what are you going to watch over time and,
and,
and buy into and it's gotta be,
you know,
really high quality because it's so competitive.
It shows her so good.
Yeah.
Americans,
I'm word nine episodes in the first season.
Season One,
I think there's five seasons.
Yeah.
It's phenomenal.
It's,
and it's really good premise.
So people understand is Russian spies that are living here,
uh,
in deep under deep cover during the 80s,
during the height of the Cold War.
And they are basically trying to,
they're giving the image that they are Americans,
right?
While they're acting for the KGB.
Yeah.
And it's men.
But the thing is that alone is a good premise.
So well layered.
The show is,
you know,
with,
well,
cause they're supposed to be married partners.
KGB,
yes.
Partners and not be romantically linked,
but they'd been going for so long and they have two kids.
So the story is like,
do we become romantically involved?
Do we trust each other and then back and forth.
Then Fbi,
FBI,
her storyline is so neat,
man.
I don't want to get back.
Some of it I think historical,
I'm sorry.
Doggies historically accurate.
Some of it is dead drops and all that cool stuff.
I love that.
KGB crap.
I when I visited the Berlin Wall and they have um,
uh,
you know,
museums purchase no checkpoint Charlie.
And you can see how people snuck in,
but when you went there,
you went,
it's in Berlin.
Yeah.
Where people are wearing clothes or I know the Europeans,
they were they naked
chicks and Ted said Berlin.
No West.
Yes.
Mostly nude.
Mostly nude or European?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well you ever been to like a European bathhouse?
They're all naked.
I've know.
I've been to Europe,
but you never went to a bad house where people go and they just sit around with
your dicks out.
I went to a semester of school and muddied.
What about topless beach?
Most of Europe you can be topless.
It's not a big deal.
Tits out.
New to these.
A little more
forgiving.
Yes.
The NF by a where I remember we watched,
uh,
the house hunters international.
I'm always blown away by it when they go like,
well,
uh,
we are,
we're married and we have,
we live in Connecticut and we have three children.
Yeah.
11.
And now they're in school.
We always kind of wanted to experience Spain.
So we're moving there and you're like,
wait,
what?
And then it's like kids are going to Majorca.
I don't want to go to my,
uh,
I want to see my friends and the not anymore.
You don't,
I don't even speak Spanish.
You'll learn you're young enough to pick it up.
Right.
But in five years,
right.
So brutal.
You do matter doing anything worse to small children.
We're going to rip you out from your friends.
Your school.
One kid was young enough in that family where like she doesn't know what's going
on.
The other two were like,
fuck off my York and I don't like how I'm on set our norm.
I want to go back.
Yeah,
of course.
Of course they do.
Well then an errors are like,
they love it
and it's like a small outskirt village too.
It's not even like,
oh city.
What a nice expensive.
That was $3 million to renovate U s 3 million.
God Damn Man.
What's the,
what's Nice there in Georgia?
But it's expensive,
right?
Like the euro is pretty good.
They're not like Hungary.
It's a little worse.
It was.
It was amazing amount of money they spent.
Could you imagine and they're like,
it took a year.
No,
it took two years to renovate.
They thought they were going to be all in their new year and there's nearly two
years.
I have no interest in renovating anything.
I see.
I told you do this.
I want to,
what do you want to renovate?
I would want,
I would want to,
I have a fantasy of buying a modest home and then doing the major renno.
I thought,
yeah,
I thought it'd be fun.
Like tearing it down and starting.
Well,
both.
I mean,
obviously there's different levels of commitment at that point.
Then money and what a nightmare.
The thing is,
La is so crazy for a housing market that,
you know,
you gotta do you have to do something out of the,
can I tell you why?
No,
just imagine the chaos.
Like,
you know,
when you have movers,
remember we were packing and you had movers come in and you're packing and the
stress of like workers.
I know,
I know every day,
but I think the way to do it would be like,
let's say it's like they did on that show you and you're in the house that
you're renting,
right?
You'll have random place.
Then you buy the other place and you start doing the work as you live in your
rental.
Yeah.
So huge commitment.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But then you end up getting into a place that you really love.
That's true.
Yeah.
You can custom it.
Well that one day when we have millions and millions,
that's the thing is in most parts of the country you could do that without
millions and millions.
I know it's a fantasy.
Well they go there literally are like parts in here.
We just saw online this a house that was for sale and then the ad for the house
was tear this down and build a house
and the house was two point $3 million.
So they're saying spend 2.3 to not Lisbon,
tear this piece of shit down.
They don't even,
didn't even try to sell you on live.
They're like blow this house sucks,
but it's a great property.
Then spend your money on top of that.
See,
but if you have that kind of cash,
you're saying by something spasming,
Rad and not,
you know,
or you could make something.
I don't know.
It all sounds like a nightmare.
I have no patience for building things.
No.
You said that like your name was Pedro.
I ain't got no.
Okay.
Just like a black mom when you said that was really good.
There you go.
But I'll tell you,
but that should do.
So speaking of patriarch starting our patriarch June 1st June 1st just so people
know,
nothing will change about this show come out the same way it came out.
Different toilet,
different toilet man.
So all we're doing is extra added bonus content,
added access,
more stuff at Patrion.
It launches Petrie on June 1st and we've already done our first Patriot on bonus
episodes.
Good till you guys are going to hear all about my brand new tennis lessons.
It's my eastern blocky.
Oh God coach.
It's really cool.
Yeah.
What else do we talk about that one to questions?
Yeah,
we did it.
We answering personal questions.
We answered questions about the show that you guys emailed in.
So if you want to know some behind the scenes stuff,
get on our patriotic,
you make a small donation.
It's like a monthly contribution and a,
there's going to be even things that people can get can win,
right?
Or no though.
When
you get into art or art club,
they can,
oh the art club and you get a piece of art that I create.
If you haven't seen my,
what I'm capable of.
If you go on my Instagram,
you can see one of my original works.
Um,
so there'll be stuff like that.
It's going to be great.
We're excited about it.
Hey,
by the way,
you know,
um,
you're well known for your art teacher jacket and somebody actually found that
if you keep that jacket on long enough,
how,
where you're like,
what you're going to,
you were doing in the future devoted to the rainbow spine.
Oh my God,
I'm so excited.
Arts and crafts department sent me to Korea now,
not a normal sponge.
This is so dense and love her.
Resizes because I can't stand just one size and I talk about
the hygiene of sponge.
I squeezed and squeezed and squeezed and squeezed.
No flab on this arm.
My cleaning Flav on this arm.
Now if you do,
I love her so much.
Of course you love her.
I want to be her.
I want to be happy like you asked for.
How do you get that happy?
You wear that jacket longer.
Wear your jacket,
your art teacher jacket.
I want her to be my mom.
Why can't my mom be nice like that lady that's all stoked about sponges and
colors and shit.
You asked for it a whole
look at the
earth tone.
Look at death.
Is this fun?
She's a great,
yeah,
I love her.
How does she get so stoked on this?
She has your checking.
I know it's a jacket that makes people happy.
So will you get involved in stuff like this?
Do you understand?
I want you so bad you could wear your jacket and come make your little sponge
stuff by both lunch 11 look how happy she is.
She's so happy.
Yeah.
Can we see more?
Can we play that again?
That was
card
being heavy.
Oh,
ah.
Oh God.
Now think oh this way.
And now we think,
oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
I can pay at a time.
Okay.
And then
this was one night that I did not so hard.
I love it.
I love her so much.
Can I take that?
I get super excited about colors too.
Like that.
Like draw and stuff.
Yeah.
I love art work like that.
Why?
I love colors too.
I get excited.
Uh,
Michael's arts and crafts,
you know,
you're really excited going in here.
You know what?
It brought us Aussies
to our attention.
The you are obviously known for your art teacher jacket.
Yeah.
Somebody wrote in,
Oh God,
here we do the show.
No,
it's going to surprise you.
Okay.
They said was the guy that was actually like,
it's upsetting because you know how emotional I'm going to get about this.
Yeah.
Let me show you.
I want people to be able to see you watching it.
Aw.
We did not safe with Nikki Glaser.
Yeah.
Um,
oh look how nice that I know somebody wrote in Tom Genes.
Where to Tommy get this jacket from.
I know.
What brand is it?
This is the greatest jacket I have ever seen.
Much better than Tina's our teacher jacket.
I must have it keep 'em high and tight.
Lots of love from mom.
Born on mom's trail.
Yeah.
Oh Mel.
I love Melbourne.
It's mom born.
Sorry.
I love mom born.
Tell me you are going to get emotional and we've been talking about this jacket
for weeks now.
Yeah.
Months.
Actually,
mm hmm.
So here's what happened,
man.
I,
um,
I actually,
you know,
like a lot of things you going to like,
I,
I've always wanted a nice jacket,
a nice leather jacket.
You never bought one.
Yeah.
And not too long ago,
I think it was December,
November,
December,
I bought the jacket you're seeing in this and it was the most expensive jacket
I've ever bought and that was 55 0%
off,
even with 50% off the most I've ever spent.
And I was like,
you know,
I justified it.
I was like,
yeah,
you know,
you've never gotten a jacket like that.
Go ahead and buy that jacket.
And then there's something about jackets that are different than other articles
of clothing where they start to feel like they're part of you,
you know,
literally they envelop you,
envelop you,
but it becomes like almost part of your personality.
Yeah.
Right.
The jacket,
you become synonymous with you.
You start wearing this jacket fit like a glove man.
And I just,
I absolutely loved this jacket and from the day we moved here,
I haven't found the jacket.
I've been looking.
You mean you lost it?
Well,
I think I did lose it,
but I wasn't sure you would have kept a better eye on it.
It's a really horrible thing to say to me.
Right.
Number softy.
Yeah.
Number one,
I lost softy.
How sympathetic where you then sure.
Maybe you should have sown your name into the tag.
Oh,
I hate you so much.
This jacket,
man.
I talked to my,
my whole shrink session last week was about this jacket.
That's all I talked about was about losing this chat.
Yeah,
it's very traumatic.
I haven't,
I've called hotels.
I just can't fucking figure it out.
I know that the cause it,
it just bothers me that it's gone
now.
This is,
okay,
so we shot this.
Is this the last time you wore that?
Oh,
I don't know man.
I don't know if it's the last time.
I don't really shot this like,
right,
right.
Like I'm,
what a month before we moved.
Well,
I don't know if it was a month before it would get down to the details.
I mean,
there's certain things I know that happened where I had the jacket.
You know?
I know when I got my photos taken,
I remember I had those.
I had the jacket for that.
I know that the jacket wasn't left there.
I checked with her.
I know that obviously I had it for this.
I know that I had it at a couple local gigs,
but you know,
I remember leaving with it.
It's gone,
but if fucking irritates the shit out of it.
Let me tell you something,
and you're shrank.
Said this to you too.
Yeah.
Jackie Karma.
You lose a jacket and you're going to gain an even better jacket.
Just watch.
You'll see it.
It'll come to you.
You're going to go to the same story that you got that at and you're going to
find an even better deal and it's going to be great.
Prompts me out.
I know you have to let it go.
You've got to let it go.
Tom.
The jacket's gone jacket like kind of tell you what I really noticed.
Not so much this,
but the hair looks great.
That haircut is that Allen.
He did that right before.
And your beard.
This is the right leg.
Three.
Yeah.
Do you know that?
It thinks I look like a fucking fat dog.
Shit.
But you look amazing.
I had just given birth like weeks before Amy Hyde.
You didn't know.
Let me get fed age 10,000 years be you look,
amaze.
And this is nice.
The color,
the cut really nicely.
How great that jacket is.
I tell you why it's not nice because it's too shiny for camera.
You look like you're about to hop on a motorcycle.
I got that when I bought
my motorcycle.
Are you Dean Del Rey?
Okay.
Listen man,
you just gotta let it go and sometimes you lose shit and you know,
but you understand that bummer.
It's a bummer man.
Of course.
I've lost a softie.
Remember my,
uh,
my childhood pillow,
I it on the road and then one time I left softy behind.
And you still like to remind me about it that when we're in bed sometimes,
yeah,
kind of getting settled in.
Do you remember when you left Softie,
but,
and you'll get really upset with me.
Well,
it's really,
I didn't mean to leave her behind.
I was an early flight that morning,
a soft pillow.
I've had it.
So I was a child,
I lost softy.
I know that is irreplaceable jacket,
you can replace that.
My shrink told me,
she goes,
well,
think of you know your jacket,
like Jacket Karma.
Like you're saying that somebody just,
who could not buy that jacket just found it and was like,
oh,
this is,
and now you gave it to him.
And she goes,
how does that make you feel?
And I go,
well,
as long as I don't see it.
And she goes,
I'm sorry.
And I go,
I mean,
it's a fight.
It's a fine fantasy.
I can live with that.
I don't see it.
I go,
but if I saw somebody wearing my jacket,
I would be like,
give him a fucking jacket.
Of course it doesn't feel good.
And she was like,
Oh,
I go actually had a fantasy that somebody tried to alter the jacket.
And then I took a knife and I cut the jacket up in front of them.
Oh Wow.
And she was like,
okay.
It's how so those talk about it.
That's really good that you're talking about your honest,
a horrible impulses though.
That's huge therapy to be honest about your shittiness.
Like when I told her,
I'm only like,
if I'm suffering,
I like it when you suffer too.
She has,
she has like,
that's really bad.
But I'm glad you shared that because when we can get rid of that impulse in me,
like if I'm unhappy,
you should be unhappy.
That's not,
no.
That's how,
that's normal.
That's not normal.
You're not normal.
And nothing's about the normal.
Yep.
Um,
this,
sorry.
Listen,
we're going to have,
there's going to be a great resolution to your loss jacket.
You'll see.
Give it some time and first of all,
even if you get it replaced,
it's not going to be the same.
It's not the same man.
It's never going to be,
it's over.
It's already bought a replacement dragon.
You did?
Yeah.
Where is it ordered it online.
Is it the same?
It's similar,
but it's not the same.
Yeah.
Let it go.
I need a jacket.
You gotta work?
[inaudible].
Ooh,
that's good.
This is gonna blow your panties.
I know,
I know.
And but switchbacks and are you today?
Good question.
Um,
I am.
Hmm,
that's a good question.
I'm feeling hungry.
So I guess Tracy,
your dad lay Tracy.
Uh,
yeah,
but I am planning my exercise so that's kind of more of a to thing.
Yeah.
I'm feeling like Towanda today.
I feel like I'm taking care of my kids.
I got my shit right.
Like [inaudible] has got her life together.
She's got her life.
I think twin has got her life together more than any of the other Braxton thing.
So she's got a past like she's,
I think she got caught even fever.
Look she out now.
There was a cop,
a police mug shot of her,
but did she doesn't do that stuff anymore.
To what does a good girl?
Well,
what do you think of this?
Like you kidding me right now?
What the fuck tone rumors are that Tony the,
this,
the real star of the Braxton clan.
Now Tamar.
But Tamar is really the breakout.
No,
no,
no.
This is legendary man.
But Tamar is really popular right now.
Dude,
are we really going to have this conversation that you're comparing Tamer to
Tony brand talent?
But I'm saying in terms of popularity,
right?
Yeah,
very positive.
Very popular.
I'll give you that.
But by far the most,
you know,
no,
no Tony Racks and there's no comparison there.
Toni Braxton,
I sing just like sophisticated grammy award winning with the real deal from the
Braxton clean is Tony and the rumors that she and Birdman are dating some
respect on my name that's crazier than shit and nobody,
like nobody would suspect that Tony would be into
super thug right here.
But this whole facial tattoos stuff is out of control.
It's real crazy,
man.
She seems classier than that's my board man.
Yeah.
That's,
it's,
it's alarming beyond alarming.
Um,
like I can see her with baby face there.
She's always talking about him and they work together.
Baby face.
I don't know if the,
as if
is saying here that did Tony just confirmed birdman is her man.
This says that they've allegedly been dating for months.
Oh my God.
God.
Are you,
are you sad?
It's just,
it's very strange to me.
I mean,
I could see that it can happen,
but it's very strange.
48 year old had been spending time with Birdman on Sunday.
He was seeing getting cozy,
this is like a week ago at her grammy performance in Brooklyn.
Um,
there was sealed off,
I guess they did a song years ago.
Oh,
they done?
Maybe.
I Dunno.
It's just,
I would never think that,
uh,
that those two would be a couple.
Especially when you watch that show,
you see how she is,
you don't see her.
But you know,
maybe he's like one of those guys who uh,
you know,
like every,
every dog has a soft heart man.
That's true.
Tom,
you don't know the bird man can be very sensitive.
Yeah.
An R and B,
you don't know that.
You don't know if he's just does all this,
you know,
shit talking,
uh,
when he has a lot of people around and the cameras and,
but at home he's a,
he's a real sweet bird.
You never know.
This is what the closed doors,
they bread.
I think I talked about it on maybe on the breakfast club.
We'll see if they break it down for us.
I love that movie.
Gotcha.
That is the thing that Toni Braxton is dating Birdman.
I seen it and that they'd been dating for quite some time now and it's been
under wraps,
but they just recently where it together.
I'll put some respect on that.
Kobe is band last night too.
I don't know if that's all right,
but I thought it was a little more insight than that.
I'm just shocked having,
like I said,
watch the show.
Uh,
you see the way that she is doesn't seem like a match,
but you know,
sometimes you can't
predict will look.
Sometimes the good girl likes the thug.
You look at Whitney Houston.
Yeah.
And what's his name?
Robbie Brown.
[inaudible] Brown.
Christina.
Bobbi.
Bobbi Kristina.
Let's do it.
Is so much more thugs in that though.
Real?
No,
I want to,
yeah,
he's got facial tattoos.
Not just that man.
This is the real thing.
I mean,
look,
he's a CEO.
He's worth the $150 million.
So that makes up for a while.
But I mean you can't compare a Bobby Brown,
Bobby Brown was just,
you know,
the guy that was drinking and smoking and showing up late and that,
that kind of,
she's not like a thug.
This guy has,
you know,
we'll come in with eight dudes and kick your fucking door down.
Shit might go down all night.
Right.
I feel like he's already upset.
That's right baby y'all are y'all finished?
Are Y'all done?
We're done
kind of a,
I dunno.
I thought that was,
but they liked the thugs.
The good girls like the thugs and Tony is so disciplined and so a straight,
you know,
if she takes care of her kid where you liked that.
Did you like the thugs?
You're a good girl.
Yeah,
and high school.
Only in high school I had a boyfriend that had a competition with his best
friend to see how long they could go without showering.
And that was the only extent of it.
And that's a bad boy to you.
He was pretty gross.
Well,
that's a gross boy necessarily a bad boy.
No,
I,
you know,
no,
no.
I,
I liked the people that treated me kindly.
I didn't like bad boy shit.
I don't need that.
I don't have time for that.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
I know how to got down with that.
Um,
real quick,
we this a email here and want to read.
Hey Hitler.
Uh,
I recently saw Tom's performance and Jack me off fill.
It was even better than I expected.
And shout out to Pat House who was fucking hilarious.
I am a huge fan of the mommy podcasts and it's the only thing that keeps me sane
when I'm staring at paperwork every work day at the show.
I was sitting in the front row and at one point Tom pointed to me and asked me
how my year was going.
I replied and I was wearing them a high end type,
but he didn't seem to want to bring up the podcast.
You guys are awesome.
I will always be looking forward to seeing your act.
My question is,
how do you feel about the crowd yelling out?
Only things true.
Mommy's would know about p I'd be honored if he brought this up.
A PSM also poly and by um,
oh better you non-binary,
respectful.
The pronouns she day,
they and them will not appreciate it.
I look man,
um,
first of all,
always appreciate our fans that listen to the show that come to shows.
People yell stuff out.
It's fine.
What I only thing I always try to,
like,
I think most people understand this is that when you go to a standup show,
you're at a standup show.
So just don't expect that that will be an extension or a representative of the
podcast because it's just two different things.
So,
uh,
you know,
yeah.
People yell stuff out from this show.
Hey Hitler.
And uh,
you got my posey talking to me.
All these things from the podcast and uh,
you know,
so it's just,
it,
it's only weird if somebody expects that the show,
like the standup show will be about the podcast.
Yeah.
I don't mind it.
Like when I go up to when I'm walking up to the stage,
I like it when they're like,
yeah.
And then it lets me know that there's mommies.
Yeah.
But then there's like one time where I was about,
you know,
halfway through my set and like a drunk mommy was like,
just yelling out all of our sayings top like yeah but now it does.
What are you doing?
Well what are you sure?
I know like I was like what do you expect to happen though?
Yeah.
I don't know.
And it doesn't want it.
That's okay.
In moderation.
I think everything in moderation.
Yeah.
It's fine to be excited.
That's my point is that the standup is just about like you're not,
it's not about the,
yeah cause we can't stop what we're doing.
And then just like rattle off sayings from the show.
Cause then cause there are people in the audience is also don't listen to your
mom.
Yeah.
And they're like,
but it's different.
If you go to a live podcast
will mean the,
then obviously we'll look dressings that are not the podcasts cause people like
in the middle of my cell and be like,
show me how those big tits far and you like,
I got to explain this for the other hand.
Somebody did the,
I remembered,
I don't remember that
this guy's the interaction.
I remember,
uh,
like a month ago I was somewhere and this guy goes a crazy lokes and I go,
what?
And he's like crazy lokes and I go,
what about him?
And he goes,
What do you,
what do you want me to do right now?
Yeah.
Weird beard.
Like and then do you understand that there's like 350 people at the show?
Yeah.
So now I you want me to like I have to put it in context for everybody.
You want me to do the whole for them to understand who that is.
Like I would have to really spend 10 minutes just giving the idea of who that
is.
Ports explain it.
Like,
dude,
I,
you know,
cause one time I tried explaining that.
Would you rather that we did?
Would you rather be retarded or get dragged off by your grandfather on the
Ferris wheel?
The audience was not keen.
Really half of them were like,
ah,
yeah,
shit,
I got to dig out of this hole.
But it's because people that listen to this show,
when you,
you say something like that context is there.
You don't have to,
that's why I live podcast.
Where you're talking about podcast up is going to be much easier to navigate.
You know what,
I'm just this totally unrelated,
but what kind of bear do you think you are?
Why?
I'm looking at your beard and I'm seeing all kinds of colors and I'm thinking,
are you grizzly or your polar brown bear bipolar.
Are you a brown bear?
I got,
that was a really good joke.
You did right there.
Someone else's,
Oh,
I'm sure if someone said it too,
but it's really I,
it's appropriate.
Oh,
bipolar bear.
Polar bipolar bear here by Polly Polly and by bear.
Jeez,
I'm a bipolar bear.
That's it.
You nailed it by volley there.
There's no need to have a good discussion anymore.
Chrisley what kind of barrel?
Our Panda Panda's tower.
Yeah.
They're so cute.
You ain't bamboo.
You couldn't be a panda cause you're Jen's hall.
I feel like with all the Brown,
I gotta be a brown butter.
I make so much brown guys right in.
Let us know which bear Tom is or just tweet tweeted him at [inaudible] dot com
Tom at Tom to grow.
Let them know if you're,
especially if you're gay and you're in the bear community.
Okay,
thanks.
I'm in the bear community.
Different types of bears or is it just stripped bear cub?
I don't know hers.
Why are you asking me is you have a huge fan base that's bear,
but they don't tell me what the details are,
but just days his post on my Instagram account.
Mm MM.
I love it so much that you have a bear of following.
You mean a find one?
I'd love to.
Let's see these columns.
I'll show you.
Um,
I'd say you're a grizzly though,
cause you do shed a lot in the woods and you eat Saulman out of the river and
you know you're more feral.
Okay.
Mommy's listening to this week's podcast.
Feeling inspired.
Why stop with giving just tore city better names.
The real mommy's need upgraded monikers.
Tom Segura could be come shit poo poorer.
Wow.
Cherry bomb shit.
Someera oh and Tina can be Celestina poo shit ski good.
And Christina flap titties.
Wow.
And content Cantina Wipe Shit.
Please.
Jeez.
What talented listeners we have should be able to keep it high and tight with
some names like that by Hitler.
Charlie.
Thank you Charlie.
Thanks Charlie.
That was really good and inspiring.
Yeah.
Um,
it's a very,
very sort of binary suggestion.
Uh,
oh,
where's the,
uh,
do you want to hear the ultimate vocal fry guy?
Yeah.
Uh,
oh,
this,
you
know,
right.
Even here,
how he normally,
no,
no.
Normal talking.
That's all he does.
He's speaking Swedish,
isn't it?
That that's yeah,
that's how you do it.
No,
no
dude,
it's ridiculous.
Hey guys,
that's got to give us the gall a run for his money.
How do we find how to refine this one?
This one was sent in,
right?
When someone send this friend,
I think you forwarded.
Oh,
but someone sent it to me.
Yeah.
This guy's a bear too.
He is.
He's got all,
he's a fan.
That's how I found out about it.
That's how I found out.
Yeah.
He's a polar bear.
Ah.
So stupid.
I know.
He looks like he's about to die to like some really unhealthy.
You think this guy is unhealthy?
Yeah.
Dot.
Good.
Cause he gonna die any minute and it's really not good.
No.
Um sure.
Ride Day.
Part Day.
Where's the fucking thing we were watching earlier?
Remember that the thing we were watching together,
you're like that has to be played on the show.
Do you what I'm talking about?
Let me,
let me see if I can find it myself.
I got,
I thought it were,
oh it must've been something that just came up.
I didn't realize that.
I don't know know.
See if I can
wait,
where were we?
I got it.
I got it when you were in bed.
Um,
cause I thought it kind of,
you know,
made sense to play with this
number now.
Yeah.
In school system has told you all your life.
Hitler was the most evil man to ever live.
Unfortunately,
you are taught lies and he most likely believed Hitler is very rarely accurately
portrayed.
You know,
even Churchill once said that the victors write the history books,
but we hear about Hitler through the media and the school says is extremely
biased.
Oh my God.
First of all,
stop the lies.
Um,
or a VA.
This antisemitic.
Shut it down.
Six gazillionaires.
Oh my God.
I mean,
look,
we have actual footage of Hitler saying killing the Jews,
the final solution and now we have footage of him being a creep.
Wait a minute.
Are you disputing with watching this video right now and the people,
cause they don't want to.
I'm going to tell you the truth,
by the way,
in this,
at least in the intro,
all the images of him or smiling or laughing,
this guy's super nice.
This is why Hitler was not evil.
In fact,
he was the opposite of that.
He was a very strong leader and a brilliant man.
I'd off Hitler,
truly cared about his people and his country that he institutionalized.
She's a real sweet voice.
And then he was evil that they chose a little girl to narrate.
Wait,
but I'm,
we're not going to see why Hillary is a good guy.
Curious to know what the argument is.
This cool video idea,
was this in my sheet or no
download boobs submitted.
It was submitted.
Okay.
That's where I came.
I didn't know where it came from
after on that.
C is a slur for national socialist.
National Socialism is a world view and philosophy.
By the way,
I didn't actually know that until I watched this video.
I learned that Nazi is,
is an national socialism by watching a video called why,
why Hitler was an evil.
I had no idea.
Oh my whole life.
That,
that's what that stood for.
Nationalism is the individual's responsibility twice the community for the
country.
Yeah.
And then I love you.
Love the Jews.
Socialism is the community's responsibility and love towards the individualized.
I don't know that most people always define these words with love in the
definition.
Basically the one who does the most for the community has the highest social
status instead of the one with the most.
Okay.
Uh,
they use a picture of little Wayne laying on a pile of money.
I think the people that made this might not be,
um,
racist.
Along with that was a process of class unification is going to be a really long
day.
Yeah.
Well anyway,
it wasn't his fault.
They're trying [inaudible] denies the Holocaust.
It's so crazy.
I mean the San People that deny the moon landing,
right.
Holocaust never happened.
It's pretty,
it's pretty small group now.
We still get together like,
um,
first Thursday of every month.
So,
uh,
I already went this one bed in June.
We'll go again.
But it's a pretty small group.
Holocaust deniers.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a very,
you have to be a real specific piece of shit.
Special special group.
How do you deny and the Albert the footage,
they faked all the footage of,
of death camps and bodies and um,
if you got,
I guess if you talked to them,
they do believe that,
that it's like,
yeah,
like they're like,
it's a few thousand people.
That's what they think.
They think that,
you know,
yeah.
You feel like more is bad.
You had a camera roll and you saw some bad shit.
All right.
That's,
that's kind of,
yeah,
that's the spin of it,
I think.
Wow.
You sound,
I mean,
there's one day,
it was just one bad day.
Yeah.
Everybody else.
Everyone's been making it up.
Um,
give Hitler a break.
Yeah.
So this guy stole a car in the UK and didn't know that the car that he stole had
a dash cam that was not just recording video,
but his audio.
Oh,
how funny was he freaking out?
I freak.
He calls somebody day,
I'll call it quality crop.
Yeah.
I'm driving at time
on jumping.
Chilean took,
keep up.
I'll get a pocket all done by them.
Okay.
Nah,
Nah.
That's too close to where the car,
where the call come from.
So we had a car come from,
well,
it kind of made me think,
I mean,
this is sort of a perfect opportunity,
ladies and gentlemen.
Tom Segura,
master of accents,
Dow,
dow down as two coasts to where to car come from.
That was really good.
I know.
What region is this?
London?
This,
yeah.
Just keep it.
Bye [inaudible] I have never been in a car light these days.
Paul will relieve for doubts anything.
Gosh.
Hey,
hey.
They saw high free BMW.
Hey.
Oh do a BMW.
That's really good.
Yeah.
And that can move.
It sounds retarded.
I'll put eats again some.
That's why I can do it.
Well,
get a buddy in.
My flash is not my mom's mind.
Uh,
my,
no,
my mom,
yes,
but don't,
I don't they have dash cams in Europe everywhere in the cars.
Not My mom's pretty common now that they do this in Europe.
Like how the fuck do you not know that every car has a dash cam on it?
Is every card?
Well in Russia,
I know they do it.
Uh,
yeah.
It's pretty prevalent because Cora thievery is,
is prevalent at this bay.
Abu Dhabi w Cam move that and people getting hit and stuff accidents.
So they,
a lot of them have dash.
So what you're saying yeah.
Is the Europeans are not just naked all the time,
but they have dash cam recording it all the time.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This car car where,
where bobe similar.
Yeah.
I'm fucking,
you know,
no middle should be a waste.
What a fucking place on this Middlesex hospital?
No,
holidays.
X.
Oh,
Pinto.
He looks like,
he sounds like he's mocking somebody British.
Right?
Holy Shit.
Really bad.
What does this accent called?
What is this master of accents?
Is this God damn fucking,
you know?
No [inaudible] no.
My both Middlesex hospital
may all say,
whoa.
Spirito can hide.
Is it bad?
Yeah,
it's really terrible,
man.
Talks like,
uh,
you told me that wouldn't know Holtz Beto a total brick calm.
I said,
I've got no curve tele.
I've got beige boxes in Bahais.
Muhajirs grace [inaudible] bro.
Fuck man.
Fuck is this guy.
So this is like a Guy Ritchie movie character robot.
Yeah,
you're right.
It is like that.
Like that they talked to Gypsies and you get to understand what this has got to
be.
A lot of that is how I learned that.
Yeah.
But this guy is like a,
yeah,
whatever they call lower class.
Speaking of master of accidents,
you know,
I'm not the only one and the,
they exist in a bunch of different places.
We have found the Japanese master of accents.
Okay.
Doing our accent.
I love when foreigners do America.
It's nominal.
I would like
cheeseburger.
Come to yen.
Jean King,
Dabo ceramic knives,
manufacturer company limited way.
Choose a specialist to manufacturer and exporter of ceramic knives.
We have an advanced to production equipment and disappear.
Where technical personnel,
who has Marvin doing years a ceramic knife making experiments.
That's quality first and a continuous innovation.
A salver persist 10 days.
No.
My favorite part of these terrace is,
you know,
on the food chain of this company,
they don't know that what he sounds like to native English.
Yes.
Somebody is like,
have you heard uh,
shogun speak English?
Yeah.
It's fucking amazing.
And he'll do,
he'll do a perfect,
I've done,
that's not what he,
he's on the hives.
What cuts through at his saying,
can we focus our attention now?
Manufacturing risk kinds of naivete and flying qualities.
Ceramic knife,
wine quality,
quality.
You said quality.
Is that quality,
quality,
no problem.
Look,
well,
how Denisa of oversee Ram make knives is over 90 degree
gray.
The problem is,
is that he learned British English first.
So he's doing it with a British accent and then trying to do American on top of
it.
Yeah.
Cause he's not only going in British,
right.
He should have just done like,
but he learned to speak at British knows.
Oh belly stone sounds like a retarded Asian.
That's why I can do it.
No.
Is that good?
Hey,
you haven't really done the retarded comedian idea,
Babe.
You're missing out on a huge market.
Do this accent go.
I'm gonna have to hear it.
Yeah.
Can stand up to me.
Just drop tests and due to the small cut stand up to meters drop test drop tay.
It's rising intensity and Oliver [inaudible] products.
My next 40 to to Europe,
which have been winning customers of Russia.
Asia.
You know what he sounds like he is palsy though.
Red Am Ha.
Why does this company,
you think not just hire an English speaker.
It's gotta be some right in Asia of course.
And then they go,
but show Jen is he's here.
Just use him.
That's not even a name is it?
Is it is showed.
Yeah.
That's only cause you make that section read English.
I drought by trout.
Put that down.
Oh,
along governmentally we can make to terrify him.
PCS making knives annually.
Terrible.
How did have high PC is my papa out pcs and this is burden.
There's someone that speaks English better than that guy.
It's like he speaks black English.
Yeah,
but then who speaks awesome Japanese.
Let me
choosing this rooftop staging ground.
You need a small army to take out these two gangs.
I'm thinking several guys with machine guns.
A couple of make in the alley.
I'm going to take out the receipts.
Throw me
how many guys?
Just one guy.
His name is Colonel Robert Sex bags compared to Robert Bag.
Mostly units.
Well,
he's your most silver weight.
300 pounds the most.
Knowing his wife,
his wife
killed him.
The drive by shooting.
The last time I asked the CIA,
you might even wonder if he ever existed.
Did you have your life to save the world?
What'd you,
you live to save the world and nobody knew you did it.
No defend against all enemies.
I still love my country.
I still love my family and I'm still it on again.
He's out of his,
this a Louisiana hot sauce commercial.
I love my country.
It's crazy.
I can still shoot a bullet.
Okay.
Tasting for,
for the absolute elite soldier that he is.
Yes.
He's a little heavy.
A little heavy.
You think so?
You don't think that most of the uh,
special forces guys are like three 2130 I've been,
I've never seen a,
a special forces guy looked that Husky.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but old.
Very old for a special forces elite.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
Don't they force you to retire?
Uh,
no.
Seen a thing that too.
I know how to fight.
I Dunno.
What the fuck.
He's so crazy.
Setting the record straight.
More excited about his other one.
There's another is the other trailer in here,
these pieces of shit just get better and better men.
Oh my gosh.
And he keeps cranking them out.
It's like woody Allen movies.
One a year.
Steven Seagal.
The woody.
Oh,
more than one a year.
That's the great thing about him.
Uh,
you know what we should do?
I wish we could do this as rent out a movie theater and do like a rocky horror
picture show with Steven Seagal movies and have just mommy's and we all watch it
and make fun of it.
What we're going to do something like that on patriotic.
I'll first round.
We're going to do that,
like have a screening and we can uh,
babe,
have you not been here?
No,
no,
but I'm saying it'd be funny to do it in a live theater.
Merrigan happen,
but I would want to,
we don't do that.
We can do that too.
Yeah.
And we can comments area and invite.
We can do that.
You know it's a pipe dream though,
Tom.
I Dunno.
Not America.
Okay.
This one.
Awesome.
When I raise your hand,
you go up.
When I raised it down,
All of these things are things that manipulate.
Those are all the things that really make for the old command boy.
Yeah.
Is eating a sandwich right now.
I need that can successfully take out the next outcome.
So
yeah,
they don't even sound,
they don't audio mix his trailers.
We need some money and then they turn the music up.
So as he's talking,
this is a key point of this trailer and they audio makes it so poorly.
You don't even know what he says.
Take out the next outcome.
Cut that trailer was like,
yeah,
it's ready to go and you cannot heal and he needs the yellow sunglasses.
So you can't even see the expression in his eyes.
There's no emotion being conveyed and you know the next year,
take out the next outcome.
Condo,
vocal fry guy.
There was a woman,
if she was irrelevant,
you were ordered to eliminate everyone.
This is what I would call unexcusable
inexcusable.
I believe that unexcusable no,
this is missing those trailers missing everything.
I'm saying fuck a lot.
I liked those trailers when he's like,
it's just a fucking joke.
Yeah,
the fucking kick all your fucking acids.
Well those trailers,
two minutes 36 that's already too long or too short.
If you're used to Seagal trailers.
I like us to golf five or six minute trailer already,
50 seconds and we have no idea what this is about.
Nice to buy something weak.
Something sentiment
shit.
A perfect,
well I will.
I think I understand the movie now.
What is it they kidnapped?
They took that guy.
Okay.
And they're going to make him into like a manufactured warrior.
Oh,
okay.
This like terminator.
I mean they could have gotten to that way sooner,
way sooner and they showed a lot of things that have nothing to do with that,
but I think that's what's going on.
See now he's breaking out of the lab.
I'm surprised that the signed up for a movie where he doesn't play the central
the weapon.
He's not the guy.
It's weird,
right?
Yeah.
What if they're like,
but there's no,
you know why a hundred pound weapon,
you know,
it's because he needs to be the trainer,
the teacher to the weapon.
He wants to be the guys like I chore.
No,
he'll diff when the weapon gets too powerful,
he'll defeat the weapon.
Yeah.
Right.
Cause that was coming and
questioning command.
No one is safe.
How are we going to be safe
and is a target of time to making the ultimate killing machine
as nights off,
I'm exhausted.
Aren't too many lives were lost.
You get this thing.
Can you give us a stick to the script
says almost there.
Okay.
Do you notice that he pulled out very clearly?
You know something else about that moment and all the other moments we've seen
so far in this.
He's been sitting in every scene.
Yeah.
And then he trains a guy,
he's like,
give me your hand.
Give me your hand.
And he did this.
You should go up.
This makes you go down.
You miss or
oh yeah.
So he's fighting weapon guy.
Oh boy.
Here we go.
Tell me what's the meaning of this truth to you?
The only thing I know how to do,
the other bad thing about a great fight scene too,
that they,
you can tell they don't even,
do you notice that Seagal doesn't take any hits on that?
No.
So there's no stakes to the fight.
Great fight scene has a back and forth and he won't allow that.
Has Ego would never,
I think it's not even the ego.
I think he's like,
I don't want to move,
fall down and stuff and get back up.
So my hip hurts.
Yeah,
it's definitely because you're right.
He never takes us single hit.
No,
no one kicks it.
Like if you watch his old stuff,
there was more like the original stuff out for justice.
It was a back and forth.
Right.
But yeah,
but you're right.
It's cause he's too lazy to eat.
Yeah.
So we'll have him kind of kick your ass for none.
None.
That just,
okay.
Cause this,
and it seems so unbelievable.
This is like the,
you're right,
it was like the fifth movie of 2016.
It's all,
it's only may.
Yeah.
He's gotten 10 movies out on bullying.
Unbelievable.
Jesus man.
Fuck.
And that is way that you're right.
Way Too long in between,
you know,
the entire film.
Horrible.
The entire film.
There's no,
no.
So he defeats the ultimate weapon.
That's it.
End of story.
Jesus,
man.
Um,
he really should lose a few though.
I mean,
look,
what do you mean you're an action star?
Some lbs.
I'm a little confused.
Uh,
I'll play the fat and say,
I've been talking to you a lot about this,
which is like,
you know,
we think is one of those things where if,
uh,
if you talk about it a lot,
we should do something about it.
Yeah.
And so
here's a little
side show recently began producing its fifth year of content,
something that we are extremely proud of.
We're also proud of the community that's grown up around these videos.
We've covered a lot of topics,
both trivial and a profound,
and
this is what sideshow,
is that what it's called?
Yeah.
Very hard to capture both our fascination and excitement as well as our
chancellor.
I took a hosting class year.
You may have a chance to comment on.
We think every single side show video asking us one question.
We have ignored this question long enough.
It is time.
We took it on Lido.
Johnny wants to know why does he have hair around his anus?
Well,
Johnny,
the reef,
well they go on to explore this and the truth is that they said they really
don't know.
Right?
We don't,
we don't know.
There's different theories in this video,
right?
One is that,
you know,
we're not evolutionarily perfect,
so there's certain things on us that um,
we just remnants of monkeys base.
Yeah,
I guess.
And that they haven't evolved to the point because there's nothing keeping it
from available.
I told you why last week.
Uh,
what's that?
To prevent the snakes from crawling up there and laying eggs.
Everybody knows that.
Snakes.
What about spiders?
Because if you're a hunter and gather,
you're sitting on rocks,
you're squatting and riverbeds stuck can crawl up there and lay eggs in your
anus.
And that's why it's good for scent.
That's right.
Trapping,
trapping in there can also sharing the scent.
If I go,
oh,
we want to sell Mel and I smell like when you put your nose down there.
That's true.
Sharing the,
this,
I bet it's something sent.
That's one of the theories.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Sent one.
Well,
people have been commenting back and forth to me about what I'm going to do
moving forward.
People were telling me to trim it.
Somebody shaved it and trim it.
So why not trim it?
Because if you trim it the now it's stubbly and short and it's going to itch and
agitate your asshole,
even that's shaving is definitely going to do that.
Yeah,
but trimming and he go straight to irritation at least with shaving.
You got a couple of days of nice and then it gets so waxing.
It's kind of where we're at right now.
But that's paint yet.
Try Wax by wax a few times,
see if that diminishes the amount of hair.
And somebody told me it's going go really badly though.
Why?
Because you're going to chase you also gonna feel the sweat more because like
hair prevents you,
you know,
it wicks away,
clicks away you and you're fighting,
playing live.
I don't know man.
It's a,
it's an interesting conundrum.
That's a big word we know.
Wax Blacks on.
All right.
Um,
what else do you got?
Anything?
Well,
we're going to do that.
You haven't pulled up or no,
you have one point.
I have one that I wrote,
uh,
pacifically for you.
Oh,
okay.
Well let me see what I got here for you,
dude.
You do boop,
boop,
boop.
You got to keep it official?
No ma'am.
Yeah.
The top layer
homeless men
have sex with your sister to face grandmother,
Washington on you masturbating.
Never have another orgasm.
Would you rather?
MMM,
we haven't answered you is because you know,
despite the fact that everyone gets their own personal pocket sized
supercomputer and then we can send robots to Mars and convert the entire face,
law it to human use.
We still,
man,
that was a lot.
I mean,
I appreciate the work that guy did,
but that was,
there was too much for me.
You know what I'm saying?
So you have a,
what'd you rather?
MMM,
yeah,
I like to hear about it.
It's just tailored to you.
So this is not a universal one.
I just thought it'd be fun to do something just for you.
Are you ready?
Are you listening?
Are you typing or are you ready?
Are you,
are you here?
Are you all done?
You're finished.
You're done.
I'm ready.
I'm pulling up.
I'm pulling up another one just so that it's a,
well then do that one first and then we'll do your personal one.
Uh,
would you rather let one man with a tiny,
tiny penis but sexy to completion or let 30 guys come on your face.
So from Thomas Cheeses.
Wow.
That is thought provoking.
I see.
I don't think that's that challenging.
It's not cause it's so tiny.
It's so tiny.
Just let it happen.
Just let out.
But then you have it already loads.
That's true.
One tiny painter and he Jesus in your butthole.
Yeah.
You're right.
30 loads on your face.
It's horrendous.
Is Tiny.
Tiny,
tiny twice.
It's like,
it's like a micro penis.
It's fine.
Yeah.
I mean that one is,
to me it's easy.
It's like it's a no brainer guy.
Just come on my butt.
Uh,
uh.
What'd you rather pick up baby James [inaudible] in a little plastic bag for the
rest of his life.
Save it forever or put bitsy and Pfo in diapers and change them all the time.
Uh,
I put busy and thief and diverse.
Then change a or then pick up a human shit off the ground with a plastic bag for
life and keep it from like he goes to college and were like,
here it is Ellis.
Yeah.
Here's the thing is you would learn to accept the fact that you're just putting
these diapers on these dogs all the time.
You just roll with it,
you know?
Plus it would actually save our carpets because Betsy has been paying on them
and now she would be able to,
shit,
I hate when somebody is,
would you rather it looks like this,
you open,
would you rather email and it's like,
dude,
what?
Get to that point
because they're having like the right 40 in there.
You know?
Now you're making me figure out which year.
What'd you rather,
these are worth a shit.
God dammit.
Go ahead.
I want to hear yours,
ma'am.
Okay.
This is just for you.
Okay?
What'd you rather listen to your dad
tell the same story over and over
for a one month.
Here's your full time Gig.
It's eight hours a day.
You had an hour lunch,
two breaks,
but it's throughout the day.
He's just telling the story over and over for eight hours.
I gotta Tell Ya,
I would tell you about the time they were telling about the Orlando airport and
I'm like,
yeah,
I in the airport.
Uh,
no,
he's,
I went to foreign
do my pants.
So I go,
I take my trousers off
and he tells you the exact same way,
exact same cadence,
exact same words,
and you've got it.
Listen,
but you got to listen.
You can't tune out the way you tuned me out.
You got to listen
babe.
Okay.
Or you have to let your beard grow for a year.
No trims,
nothing.
Just let it grow.
Let it get bushier.
Let those flavors sinking.
They get itchy or let that top hair grow right into your mouth like it almost is
right now.
That's it.
It's so easy.
What are the fucking
beard,
man?
No,
but you told me last night I would have personal hell.
It is for you and your beard is too long.
It's every day to my father for one month.
Your full time job is for one month your dad a year of the beard.
Not even,
not even okay.
Quite about your beard,
but with
peads is stank on it.
You just ate pizza and it smells like that cheese.
That's different.
That's what I'm saying.
You,
you told me I had to up the second one,
so I'm upping the stakes.
It's smells.
Smells like pizza.
Yeah.
So let's,
yeah,
let's get it as far as for a year.
So let's,
let's up the ante because I obviously I didn't make it severe enough for,
you know,
washing the beard and no trimming the beard for one year.
Everything.
You eat the flavor stand there
now think about it.
It's going to fuck up your relationship with me cause I'm not going to want to
kiss you.
It's going to fuck up your relationship with Ellis.
He's not going to want to kiss you.
Yeah,
I listen to my dad then,
but that's gonna make me suicidal.
If he tells me the same story three times in a week,
I go fucking crazy.
I know.
That's why I picked it.
It's good personal hell garden.
I also hate when my beard smells like farts.
I know.
That's why I chose it.
It's really,
it's interesting.
I think that the smell is enough of a deterrent where I would take the
psychological trauma because I know it'll end in a god buddy.
David.
Tell you the time at the Orlando Airport and see those,
or at least funny stories.
There's one thing that tells me,
I know,
it's like,
it's gotta be mundane one,
it's the same story.
And he tells it to you like it's the first time for him.
Yeah,
buddy.
I got to tell you a story.
I was golfing the other day.
Yeah.
It's gotta be something real fucking,
yeah.
Yeah.
I ever tell you about how they,
that's how it usually is.
Okay.
I went,
I know my friend George was a,
he said his,
uh,
is that he's at the restaurant and he asked for the ice tea and they brought
them all a water glaring is paying attention.
You have to pay attention though.
Fuck.
Are you telling me the story for it?
But you have to pay attention.
Yeah,
I know.
I'm trying to.
Um,
it's,
it's a good,
it is good.
Uh,
I,
and when you eat cheese,
your beard smells horrible.
Yeah.
It smells like shit.
Oh my God.
Can we look at this for a second way?
What are you picking?
I'm going to take a,
I'm going to take his,
I'm going to take the farts.
The smell.
Yeah.
Cause I get,
I wouldn't be able to tolerate a month.
I think a day I might kill myself.
I wouldn't be able to do it,
but I won't kiss you for a year.
I'll be like,
Yo,
come to kiss me.
I'd be like,
yeah,
but you're,
what you're saying is like,
would you like some love and affection?
Yeah.
Or to be,
or to actually think about committing suicide and killing yourself.
I think,
uh,
I think I would do that.
I think I would take the lack of affection for,
for a minute.
You know,
we,
I cannot believe we haven't addressed this yet.
This is really,
really worth talking about.
What,
well,
let me pull this up.
Um,
sure.
Charlotte,
by the way,
I tweeted that I started,
but it was a false alarm.
I didn't really sharp.
You didn't really by far farted hard and I was alone.
I was like,
oh look,
I,
I startled a little bit cause I'm like,
it was too brisk and it felt like there was a pub at the end of it and I just
pooped later.
But I did not sharp.
Thank you for your concern.
That's what,
what are you telling me this for?
I don't know cause I tweeted it and I just felt like it was relevant while
you're looking for some,
if you go on iTunes.
Yeah.
Jeff Tate,
friend of the show.
Yes.
Hot dogs and Gatorade.
He hasn't had a new album come out and I can't get a large image of it
but
oh,
on his album cover command plus.
Okay.
I don't know really how to make things bigger dude.
And
he did it.
Hot dogs and gator aid.
It's called Jeff Tate again.
Just one of the best comedians working today.
Okay.
Jeff.
So funny.
Nominal comic.
And He's put out a number of albums.
His latest album is called again and it's him and it looks like he's at a
restaurant or a diner or something.
Right.
Is that where he's at?
It was,
it looked like to you.
He usually eats in the seven 11 parking lot,
but yeah.
Yeah.
But he's sitting at a table and he's got hotdogs and Gatorade.
I love it on the table.
I mean you,
you realize the implications of this.
This man could have put anything on his album cover and this is a direct tip of
the hat to your mom's house guys.
So honored.
Thank you Jeff tape.
Thank you Jeff.
Tape.
Please go on iTunes or Amazon and get the album is called again.
He will not disappoint you.
I promise.
He's one of the funniest dudes.
Great Storyteller.
Uh,
it's just a hard working awesome comic,
but he's got,
he's got it hot dogs and Gatorade.
And for those of you don't know the story,
Jeff Tate lived on our couch for like a week and change.
Yeah.
And I think he was going through a rough time and he was sleeping on our couch
and we live next door to a seven 11 and I would cook and offer him meals.
You know,
he want some dinner.
Nope.
I'm going to get my own thing.
And then he would come back with two hot dogs and a thing.
I like blue or red Gatorade and that's all he ate for the entire time he lived
on our couch.
Yeah,
he was having a bad week.
He was having a bad week.
But that's all he ate.
But then he is,
but then we got to tell everybody about how Jeff Tate lives on hot docs and data
and then he would have like a blue ring around his mouth cause that's,
oh,
and can you pull that up?
There's a handmade sign.
Somebody who made this for us one time.
This is for Jeff.
Yeah,
there it is.
Hotdogs and Gatorade.
So good.
I thought was a great ride.
Anyways,
he's so funny.
Amazing.
And He loves Tom.
Tom Petty,
right?
Isn't that,
yeah.
Uh,
would you rather finally shit your pants in public once a year or subtly in
private daily.
Oh,
I mean I almost do every day since my,
I gave birth,
but come on,
I almost shit my pants constantly now.
Right.
But this is not about almost doing it.
This is about doing it privately every day.
Of course I'm here,
I'm hearing a lot over once a year in public,
you're talking about every single day you shit your pants.
And
here's why this is psychological warfare.
No,
hear me.
See
the problem with once a year is it every morning you're going to wake up and go
is today the day I have to shit my pants and public because of this.
Would you?
So you're
going to live in constant fear of shitting your pants in public and it could be
an inopportune time.
You're on an airplane.
Yeah.
Think about that.
Yeah,
you've got four hours on that flight,
but it becomes who you are.
You know,
it's like the guy that wears a fucking a fedora everywhere.
That's part of the outfit.
You Shit.
And your once a year,
you know it's going to be a fucking party.
Okay.
You're going to have a great story.
Guess what happened today?
I went to except the congressional medal of honor and as the president and put
it around my neck.
I Shit my pants.
Yeah.
Why?
Cause I play.
Would you rather?
Yeah.
Cause I have two roles now.
The psychological torture of it.
Dude,
I'm taking once a year in public.
You would?
Okay.
Uh,
no,
we got to wrap this up.
I was a good one,
which is fun today.
Um,
we have a,
I was told a great outgoing song.
It's,
um,
let's see.
Where is it?
It is the closing song.
It's by crooked cuts,
crooked cuts.
It's called song for mommies.
Um,
please go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Please go to Tom segura.com for shows my tickets.
Please go to a thousand ranch.com.
Oh,
listen to that deep,
bro.
That's April podcast.com.
It's not that deep.
Don't worry.
Uh,
I also have a charge it to the game podcast.
My football podcast is back.
I did last week in episode with Michael Reus,
former Tennessee tight 10 for 10 years.
So a lot of teas.
Bitsy licking the microphone.
That's awesome.
Uh,
it's great.
We have,
we have a fun football talk.
Uh,
go.
If you want to email our producer blue band,
you can email him your mom's blue banner@gmail.com.
That's a direct email to him.
If you want to email the show,
it's your mom's podcast@gmail.com uh,
address,
uh,
three 21 north pass avenue,
Burbank,
California nine one five oh five.
If you mail something to our Po box,
please put your mom's house on it.
If you put our names on it,
we don't get to pick it up.
That's the way it was set up.
Um,
uh,
don't forget our,
our son Perry trout is going to be June 1st.
We're launching this Patreon called Patriots.
Huh?
Tell him it's time for dinner.
Additional content and access.
Petra.
I'll get it here.
All right.
Anything else,
James?
Uh,
thank you for listening.
Thank you for supporting us.
We really appreciate it and we love you.
All right.
And that's that.
That's that.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Mommy
stops.
Oh,
I've always done this because you're a bear.
You're not a person.
No,
that's how you do it.
It's how you do that.